hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde ich sitze hier nicht alleine
sondern mit serbien
wir haben uns heute hier versammelt weil
wir zusammen den clever bot spielen
wollten wir haben ja schon ein bisschen
mit ihm geschrieben zum beispiel gut und
die ja er hat geschrieben auch danke der
nachfrage super bis zu sein du auch
nicht was schreiben wird erstmalig zur
erklärung clever bord ist eine website
wir können mit dem schreiben und der
antwortete er kennt den körper bist du
dich ja ich stehe eben was hast du heute
gegessen was richtiges montag fünf
menschen oder wie ein name sprachen
lernen was ist deine lieblingsfarbe
da sind so richtig icq fragen grünen
laut hey das ist entscheide dich alter
ich will mich kennenlernen für dich
kennenlernen schreib mal ich bin heiß
aber die ganze zeit ich bin aber heißer
als du als du so okay du hast
wir schreiben seine heutige rathaus in
wirklichkeit ist sandra 20 jahre okay
ich liebe diesen namen wie heißt du denn
schreiben immer der schreibt sage ich
nicht warum sagt er sich seinen namen
nennen und nachname der inhalt sich der
orientalische an der name deshalb dort
ist ein ist der damen okay finde ich gut
ja okay ich würde sagen wir wir kommen
wieder mit normalen fragen was das ist
doch fragen wie habe ich die noch nie
gefragt
ja was ist denn so witzig trotzdem denke
ich dich ein clever bot nein nein nein
[Musik]
eine ist die clever bot ich dachte zeit
der clever was mein leben lang mit einer
lüge gelebt sondern das gespräch so ein
bisschen neugier auf leben so werden
jetzt den komischen start mit dem clever
bord komische fragen komischer aussagen
also dass er jetzt wieder normal statt
mit einer normalen frage was ist dein
lieblingstier
[Musik]
überhaupt weniger kassen packers er
kennt ihr diese orte molina freude von
uns hat in der gruppe geschickt werden
hier mal ein sehr süßes dem auf der
ganzen welt ich mal sagen was mainz ist
elefant giraffe diese typischen so tiere
einfach elefanten giraffen was ist dein
lieblingstier frage ich jetzt einfach
mal den clever bot ich mag schreiben
welt freundlich fragezeichen was für
umwelt
wenn die tiere mag ja wieso denn als nur
eine ehre
wieso denn weil meine freundin schluss
gemacht nicht in den streit warum denn
sonst schreibt mal bedrohlich keiner
betrogen hatte betrogen fragezeichen
wieso kannst du mit 226 1424 leuten
reden schreibt man wahrlich cool bin
ganz miteinander vorbei gebe es nicht
ich habe schon einen korb gegeben was
hast du nein ich bin ein mädchen
[Musik]
wir starten das alles noch mal neue
guten tag schreibe ich jetzt aber das
wäre gegen reinstetten hallo
ok jetzt war ich einfach mal wie geht's
dir so direkt zu beginn eine lage und
die wii geht es uns auch etwas
das ist schön schön ist mein po
[Musik]
red
meine aussagen branding nicht da wo du
bist doch richtig kindergarten
unterhaltung nein hinter mir seine
wochen in den neben diesem band gewinnt
mein onkel nennt nicht mehr kannte weil
er gesagt mein onkel nimmt scheiße nein
ich habe dich noch nie geliebt schreib
mal ich bin aber hübsch
ich fand mich die ganze einfach meine
ähnlichkeit sind ich bin aber hübsch
macht ein foto von dir
schreib mal für 100 euro jahrhundert
euro jahr für mich weil ich dich nicht
kenne und dich auch nicht kennen lernen
möchte corp fragezeichen
der ist voll frech zu uns ihre e mails
haben und somit auch ein bisschen
frecher werden schreibt schreibt du
siehst aus wie ein klopapier stück wir
haben uns in deinen pc gehackt schreibe
ich einfach mal vielleicht richter dann
angst weil ich weiß wir nicht wir sind
über 20 do bis 20 bin 23 erzählst du mir
eine geschichte es war einmal ein
mädchen die war mit einem wunderbaren
jungen zusammen ende
dinge die sandra noch nie erlebt hat tag
eins single ich bin die prinzessin auf
der erbse ist die hass auf der bremse er
weiß gar nicht was wir schreiben soll
erhöhte meter abgestürzt ich glaubte die
sache beendet
der check dass wir uns reingehängt haben
abgeschrieben nein wirst du nicht
doch was seine macht ich kann zaubern
du kannst nicht hab ich aber kann ich
kann ich nachdenklich aber kann ich
nicht zeigen die opfer
fühlst du dich wieder ja sind wir auch
super
es gab mal du auch braucht ein erstes
opfer opfers auch so eine dumme
beleidigung einfach spaß ist seine
lieblings okay was sie können es wieder
das gespräch von unten herauf cool
entspannt anfangen
okay was sagen wir was deine
lieblingsfarbe sowie deine fresse ich
bin aber ein junge hat er geantwortet
mädchen und ich bin aber kein mädchen
ich schreibe ja auch er ist wie ihr buch
der weiß gar nicht dass sie zu zweit den
trainer lukas unter anderem sandra und
lukas sandra und lukas aus sondern danke
danke das freut mich zu hören
keiner aber nicht nein der soll als
verantworten
23 ich schreib korrekt mit dem ich
schreibe ernst hat okay ich auch wollen
was aber noch zu unter 20 vor stimmen
warst du aber noch unter 20 punkten
ja das bin ja ja ja ja ich bin ein
mädchen da hoffst du willst verhelfen
ich liebe dich schreiben blieb nur meine
mutter und ein vater ja was hast du gar
nix das ist nicht dein ernst
doch ja nein das hat meine fresse
fragezeichen
[Gelächter]
ok damit frisst der frage zweck tun wir
gar nichts der will nicht unsicher so
sei eigentlich wir wollen voll diovan
unterhaltung aber schon warum komme
beenden das wir jetzt nochmal mit einer
freundlichen nachricht und bedanken uns
beim klamotten schreiben einfach danke
comma dass wir ein video mit ihr
aufnehmen durch zum punkt punkt punkt
hdl sind wir nicht
papiss nicht okay an der schönheit ist
das heutige video auch beenden einige
leute haben die kommentare geschrieben
hat sich mit sandra mal wieder mit dem
clever bord reden soll beziehungsweise
nicht mal wieder sondern sandra hat mit
dem thema das auch gar nicht dass dieses
kleine ort existiert ich bin in der
internet welt ein bisschen
aufgeschmissen halter
[Musik]